Republican senator Joni Ernst of Iowa is
with us from Capitol Hill senator good
morning good morning John thank you very
much senator on the question of the
Cavanaugh nomination Democrats are
saying that his descriptions of his past
don't match the record is that important
to you well what we will rely on is the
supplemental FBI investigation that is
coming forward and I am anxious to
review the information is there
particular question you're anxious to
get to the bottom up well what we want
to see is is there evidence or
corroboration that the FBI is is able to
find through the Supplemental
investigation that would corroborate dr.
Ford's accusations and if not I will
continue to support Judge Cavanaugh
based on the information that I have at
this time what message does a vote of
support for the judge Cavanaugh send to
women in America what message that sends
to women and in America is that we are
innocent until proven guilty in this
great country and I have absolutely no
doubt after reviewing a dr. Ford's
testimony that she has suffered from
something very traumatic in her lifetime
but simply the corroboration wasn't
there with even the witnesses that she
brought forward so believe me we want
accuse those that are accusing others to
come forward if they have experienced
something in their lifetime it is
important that they are heard but again
in the United States people are innocent
until proven guilty
she said senator that she was 100%
certain and she also said that she knew
Brett Kavanaugh does that matter well it
is what she has stated however the
witnesses that she named have either
denied those claims or cannot
corroborate so which I do believe hurt
her even more so but again I do believe
that she has suffered from something
very traumatic
I do have doubt that it was Brett
Kavanaugh senator let me ask you about
the new trade deal president Trump
thanked you by name in his remarks
yesterday specifically saying that the
deal with Mexico and Canada was welcome
news for Iowa farmers and ranchers
explain for us how the
we'll help farmers in Iowa absolutely
this is a great opportunity and I want
to thank the president and our United
States Trade Representative Allah
playing field for wheat as well so we
are very excited about the opportunity
to get our commodities out into Canada
and Mexico and continue on with that
great relationship I understand it but
can you explain how it does that well we
haven't seen the the negotiated text of
the the language that's being put out
there for the agreement and I do look
forward to going through that very
specific text but we do know that we all
feel as Americans and Canadians and
Mexicans that this is a great way
forward it is modernizing but what was
NAFTA and we have an even stronger
agreement now one of the criticisms
senator is that a lot of political and
negotiating capital was expended over
the course of a year and essentially
what's been agreed to is what was in
place for Iowa farmers under NAFTA and
that then in addition there are those
steel tariffs that are retaliatory
they're causing retaliatory tariffs for
farmers and pork producers in Iowa still
creating a problem so that actually for
Iowa there's been a lot of noise but
actually things are essentially where
they were with the little exception on
the dairy well I would disagree because
AG was very strong in NAFTA already and
what we have done is provided even
greater opportunities so as we work
through this bill one of the things that
I stressed to the president was make
sure that AG comes out as good if not
better as we move into the new agreement
he was able to succeed in that area and
believe me it
a wonderful win for our dairy farmers
it's very important to them and we also
produce a lot of eggs and poultry in
Iowa as well
there will be greater access for Turkey
to so I see it as a great win for Iowa
farmers and ranchers all right senator
Joni Ernst thanks so much for being with
us thank you very much thank you have a
good day